it's time for roses and rose hey it's
here it's champagne it's different but
this shows pretty much the same
Bachelorette pretty much the same this
week kind of a filler episode hometown
visits but I still loved it guys tonight
I have rosacea champagne it's full of
bubbles or at least it was and it's
making me just full of gas I thought
about playing a drinking game tonight
where a drink every time Jojo mentions
Ben Ben told me everything that I wanted
to hear or cries but then I realized I
would die I didn't do this
we started the episode off strong with
Jojo meeting chase in the snowy
mountains of Colorado I'm gonna sum up
chases visit as chase child of divorce
broken homes his words not mine I'm
coming from a broken home he has a hard
time saying I love you bet that'll come
up later
next we had short this is the hometown
visit we've all been waiting for we're
going to meet Rogers but not Aaron Aaron
for lineout Freight I'm not going to do
that I feel like I need more for the
first time we're gonna take a break be
right back I finished oh don't drink and
drive
but do drink in Bachelorette anyway
we're gonna meet the Roger's family and
will they talk about Aaron the answer
kind of the three best parts of Jordans
family visit one Jordan's mom she has a
southern accent we don't know why it's
been so fun she seems like the nicest
lady alive and she called Jordan spicy
but well-behaved a combination of spicy
but well well behaved here's to you
ladies name I forget the dad's name is
Ed another favorite part of their visit
for me here is this moment where they're
sitting down to dinner and the producers
made sure there were two empty chairs at
the end of the table and Jojo says
there's two empty seats and I know that
they all probably wish Aaron was sitting
notice notice notice she didn't bring up
Olivia Munn some people claim that
Olivia Munn is part of the reason aaron
has estranged from his family what do
you think I don't know it's a bold
statement I'm not making it I'm just
repeating it what does everyone think
let me know
my third favorite part of the Rogerson
the hometown visits Aaron's face was
blurred out of the photos I can't
confirm it was him his face was blurred
out we didn't learn much more about why
the estrangement happened but but they
only seem really sad the parents seems
really nice I felt really bad make
things work
next we had Robbie's hometown visit and
Robbie was just jonesing for Jojo to get
there I've been excited first day for a
while has a reminder he said I love you
before anyone else did I told you I
loved you in Uruguay this is all I've
been waiting for unrealistically early
my favorite part of Robbie's family his
brothers have the exact same freaking
hairstylist him I legitimately thought
that there were only two people on the
planet with that hair Robbie and a Ken
doll also go to et online.com to check
out all of the bachelor contestant
doppelgangers we put them all together
cheer CT online calm I work there then
some drama Robbie's mom dropped a bomb
didn't mean for that survive look that's
a reality show I'd watch mom stressing
box Robbie's mom tells them that his ex
girlfriends roommate been spreading
rumors about Robbie being on the show
for pom-pom Bob the wrong reasons they
talked about it things are fun yeah last
but not least little Luke there's not
much to say about Luke's visit it was
cute it was country there was a barbecue
he made a heart-shaped out of rose
petals for Jojo to prove to her how much
he loved her
but here's the thing cut to the rose
ceremony it's in an airport hangar we
don't really know why it's very
Casablanca I think I need to say goodbye
to Luke and then Luke says he's got a
pole Jojo aside to tell her something I
needed to tell you that I'm in love with
you you know that was the producer being
like dude you should do this because
like you're about to go home Luke Bulger
how much he loved her and she was crying
and sobbing and so torn so we ended with
tears and a cliffhanger now the question
is will Jojo still send Luke home or did
his big move change your mind will Jojo
still be wearing in that sparkly dress
next week or will she go with something
more monotone I don't know huh
let me know what you think over on
Twitter and let me know if you have any
road day recommendations thank you so
much for watching we are out of rose'
but please subscribe to e t--'s youtube
page because we are not out of videos
fain